[Musique]
si vous pensiez ne pas avoir de chance
dans la vie comme ce gars ou bien ce
skieur
attendait de rencontrer jean françois
daraud l'homme le plus malchanceux de
france j'ai eu 14 mois d'hôpital j'étais
cliniques comme un mort j'ai fait un
combat d'hommes moi et oui après un
premier bobo à l'âge de 5 ans
jean-françois surnommé monsieur
scoumoune accumule aujourd'hui 35
accidents 40 fracture fin de 2000 jours
d'hôpital 3com à 6 mois de paralysie 3
traumatisme crânien et plus de 1000
jours de plâtre il collectionne comme
des timbres mon bras droit
jambe gauche et même quand il est
tranquille ou devant la télé là aussi il
lui arrive que des galères j'étais
tranquille aux mamelons thomann y
installer dans mon canapé la soirée
avait un orage et puis tout d'un coup la
foudre est tombée sur ma maison tout a
explosé chez moi tout a cramé jean
françois est tellement un habitué des
accidents qui dit carrément devenu
poteau avec son assureur
mais comme on était avec nous ce soir
sur le plateau pour nous raconter toutes
ces mésaventures mais bon ne restez pas
trop près de lui quand même on ne sait
jamais
alors voir bon alors c'est un c'est
incroyable ce diable c'est un essai sur
tout ce qui est coincé que je vous
remercie d'avoir dédié le titre votre
émission parce que jusque et une semaine
j'avais mes deux yeux fonctionné jeudi
dernier en sortant du dernier conseil
municipal et et juste après mais j'ai
perdu la vision de montlaur et c'est
pour ça vous participez
donc que vous appeliez votre émission et
les petits yeux voilà je pense que c'est
une jolie dédicace que vous me fait
mériter cet état plaisir quand même
temps c'est dommage de perdre donc vous
voyez plus dans l'oeil et sans raison
mais je suis allé j'ai passé tout le
week end dernier je vous le souhaite pas
aux urgences aux urgences
gui-de-chauliac à montpellier puisque je
suis donné mais il n'y a pas de
d'urgence entre temps et je suis arrivé
à 9h le matin et j'ai eu droit à une
chambre à trois heures le lendemain 8h
week end à me faire j'imagine bon là
sinon ça va mais oui
alors comment le sourire avec lequel
vous maquiller la chaleur et le bonheur
ça
comment a commencé votre vie de deux
balles chance ki moon a aidé
quasi maman je sais pas là donc j'ai
commencé
la naissance tout s'est bien passé
ça a été ça pue à lewis à la naissance
ça va pas tomber du bertossa bournac
après on avance on avance un peu et puis
vers l'âge de 16 suis un peu commun
comme obélix obélix est tombé ça que
potion magique quand il était petit mais
moi c'est un peu pareil
je suis je suis dans mon petit village
natal du côté de ma mère dans le gard à
saint laurent d'aigouze et la c
on joue avec mon cousin est un sauveur
joue à cache-cache je me cache derrière
la grande porte de la cave il me fait
peur sur le cul sur le coup de la peur
je recule the earth la margelle de la
cuvée je suis tombé dans une cuve de vin
j'ai failli me donc mourir noyé à cause
des émanations toxiques dans la vinasse
et c'est pour ça comme obélix je n'ai
plus droit
à partir de quand vous le dis
franchement je suis scoumoune est pas
moins qu'il est parce que moi je pensais
que c'était normal ça je suis daltonien
si on vous explique pas qu'il ya des
couleurs mais aussi
wii pas le sait pas motiver qu'il ait
découvert d'ailleurs ces journalistes et
je lui rends hommage rédacteur en chef
de la dépêche
jacques arino et je passais
régulièrement devant on était voisins et
puis moi je crois que ça fait normal
qu'un jour il m'a abordé m'a dit mais
jean-françois je dois passer une journée
comme halal le flat
avec un plâtre avec un bandeau sur
l'oeil avec une minerve est ce qu'on
peut faire un petit total et c'est lui
qui a cours 26 min c'est lui c'est lui
qui a trouvé le nombre de chevaux moule
et ça a commencé voilà comme ça par 40
fracture whitera 2 bras 2 jambes ce
serait beaucoup de fractures part ça
fait pas évidemment pas même temps par
des accidents c'est à dire que moi je
suis pour rien c'est à dire que dès que
dès qu'un fou qui prennent l'autoroute à
contre sens c'est pour moi c'est pas moi
qui prends l'autoroute en ont recensé
l'autre personne ça vous arrive hélas
tout ça ça m'est arrivé je vous les
voyez ils feu rouge vous croyez sévère
évidemment
1895 jours d'hôpital oui maintenant j'ai
dépassé les 2000 impasse qu'adrien sur
l'île depuis que le livre est sorti j'ai
dépassé les et donner
de l'air au secours si vous n'avez pas
de chance alors ici alors vous vous ne
alors vous jouez à aucun jeu de chance
ça sert à rien ça sert à rien pas de
gâteau grâce
ni loto euro millions tout s'attendant
mal et harry mais même pas un petit rien
petit à petit grâce grave que dans les
accords alors je porte bonheur aux
autres par contre
les numéros de loto c'est un peu
convention de toucher la bourse d'ubs
ont su toucher toucher la bête
vous avez 1095 jour de plâtre oui oui
oui oui c'est énorme ça fait plus de
trois annan le pl
a compté alors que là c'est moins drôle
3com ah oui droit commun et 3
traumatisme crânien qui n'ont rien à
voir avec ça c'était pas les mêmes c'est
affronter comar et traumatisé fromage et
dessert ah oui quand-même ccc c'est
incroyable et et vous êtes mariés
divorcés évidemment
est
ce que votre ex femme elle est partie
parce qu'elle en avait ras-le-bol de
faux accident ça fait partie avec tout
le pognon
alors ça dans ces cas là jusqu'au bout
mais aussi
quand même j'ai pas parce que c'est mon
genre donc
[Rires]
nous avons une chaudière
si je peux me permettre daniel quitte à
commencer peut être évitée monsieur
c'est quand même c'est vraiment un
parcours incroyable quand même là
maintenant c'est bon vous avez fait le
tour c'est bon on faisait pas tout à
fait parce que regarder
la gt ces derniers jours et je vous
parle que des derniers jours e
ça fait j'ai eu deux grains graves
dégâts des eaux chez moi c'est retrouver
ma chose et
j'ai vu les photos jusqu'à ce matin il
faisait 10 degrés chez moi la riche et
moi parce que dans le pôle et ils ont
mis plus d'un mois me réparer le
chauffe-eau d'accord pado du coup
comment il ya eu ce dégât des eaux ça
m'a fait électrique parce que
l'électricité 1 sur exposé pas de
chauffage dont bien évidemment et puis
vendredi dernier j'animais avec mes amis
du club de limoux que que je suis là
aujourd'hui je suis vite et l'avion voix
voilà mes avions ont été détournés en
fait mais ça aussi c'est l'histoire que
je suis là j'anime leur loto pour le
téléthon
on ferme la salle polyvalente de
du village global et en sortant à 1h30
du matin alors que l avait démarré là ma
voiture pour aller juste à la sortie
mais là il a plu des marques et est donc
à 1h30 du matin j'ai de nouveau appelé
le truc donc tout s'enchaîne mon oeil le
voilà ça c'est juste la dernière semaine
ecoutez jean françois si vous voulez
connaître toute l'histoire de
jean-françois les galères de monsieur
scoumoune voilà pour le bas pour ne pas
que ça vous arrive enfin parce que c'est
quand même avec toutes ces mésaventures
est ce que votre moral est impactée
au contraire aux normes et moi je suis
au dès que je me lève le matin je suis
content baba déjà
je serais vous je me suis je mais chaque
jour est un bonheur parce que c'est
confirmé c'est justement leur ont
renouvelé la preuve c'est que
très rarement non non je n'ai pas l'air
il a
calé vous l'assuré je vous le confirme
je suis pas responsable des accidents
c'est le super bonus j'aimais 12 points
etc mais malgré que vous soyez jamais
responsable que l'assureur se retourne
contre la partie adverse il vous virer
quand même ça m'est arrivé là j'ai
resigné de 15 euros comprend comment je
vous ai viré l'assureur moi je comprends
avec oui mais c'est pas ma faute je vous
en prie